merci d'être là c'est le retour de
l'émission il est 19h41 on est en direct
merci d'être là les chéris merci d'être
aussi nombreux à nous laisser des
messages et merci d'être aussi nombreux
à nous regarder depuis maintenant 12 ans
on est de retour avec toute l'équipe et
on va parler de l'héroïne de l'été pour
démarrer on va revenir sur Lana c'est
une petite fille de 7 ans qui a sauvé sa
mère vous allez voir cette histoire est
complètement folle la pelle a été
enregistrée puisqu'elle a appelé
elle-même les secours vous allez voir et
écouter audio de la nappe puisque elle
va nous raconter bien sûr toute
l'histoire elle va être accompagnée de
sa maman dans un instant écoutez ce qu'a
fait Lana
[Musique]
d'accord et ta maman elle est sur le dos
là
est-ce que tu peux la mettre sur le dos
ta maman ou pas s'il te plaît tu peux
elle te répond tu lui dis quand tu
l'appelles
maman
mais là sur le dos s'il te plaît
aller sur le dos de ta maman
est-ce que tu peux tu peux mettre ton
oreille à côté de son nez me dire si il
y a de l'air qui sort de son nez
[Musique]
ce que tu fais
s'il vous plaît on reste en ligne à
quelle heure
vous pouvez la surveiller d'accord
si Lana merci massive
nana merci d'être là c'est ton c'est
incroyable ce que tu as fait
c'est fou alors raconte-nous parce que
tu es tu es vraiment pour nous l'héroïne
de cet été qu'est-ce qui s'est passé le
13 juillet dernier tu as sauvé ta maman
donc tu es à la maison c'est ça
sortait pas bien on va manger notre
goûter on est monté après on est red on
a débarrassé la table et après on est
remonté et normalement après ma maman
elle était en train de dormir on me
disait maman maman mais elle arrive pas
à se réveiller après on a un jeu que
j'ai pensé au 18 bah j'ai appelé les
pompiers c'est avec qui ma sœur
alors que là est-ce que tu peux nous
raconter pourquoi tu as appelé le 18
comment tu savais que c'était le 18
parce qu'en fait c'était les jours de
mon anniversaire vu que je suis et mon
anniversaire c'est le 18 novembre
tu savais que c'était le numéro
d'urgence parce que ma mère elle l'école
ils m'ont appris
tu as eu peur quand tu as vu ta maman
comme ça tu t'es dit il faut que je
fasse vite quelque chose
oui t'as pas paniqué quand parce que le
pompier il est extraordinaire aussi
incroyable et c'est vrai que papa
tu t'es tu as tout bien fait tu t'es dit
il faut pas que je panique il faut que
j'essaie de sauver maman
alors s'il va c'est une histoire de fou
qu'est-ce qui vous est arrivé jour là
j'ai fait un malaise
je me sentais pas bien déjà depuis le
début de la journée
donc on est parti au travail je suis
parti avec mes filles je suis rentrée un
peu plus tôt et je me sentais pas très
bien donc je suis monté dans ma chambre
je me suis allongée pour garder un peu
mon téléphone ça m'arrive de dormir mais
après quand elle m'appelle je réponds je
réponds directement et là je pense c'est
vu que j'ai pas répondu que c'est
vraiment pas dans mes habitudes de ne
pas répondre donc de là ben voilà elle a
appelé les pompiers
c'est un malaise c'est un malaise vagal
en fait j'ai fait une peau glycémie une
chute de tension en gros c'était tout ça
par rapport à un surmenage en fait à la
maison en fait le travail la maison des
enfants toute seule avec un chien en
plus
et c'est vrai que tu comprenais toutes
les explications du pompier
tu as tout bien fait
parce que elle c'était pas facile ce
qu'il demandait quand même c'était pas
facile ce qui est drôle
et alors tu as été chercher il t'a
demandé d'aller chercher un voisin ou
une voisine était sorti je suis sortie
je suis passé sous le portail et après
je suis parti chercher la voisine en
courant avec ma sœur et tu lui as dit
quoi la voisine je lui ai dit c'est le
pompier je lui ai passé le téléphone et
donc il lui a dit
tu as gardé ton calme
et là tu as été soulagé quand les
pompiers sont arrivés
qu'est-ce que vous lui avez dit quand
vous avez appris que tout ce qu'elle
avait fait en gros je savais grosso modo
ce qui s'était passé
mais j'avais pas tous les détails
comme l'audio que j'ai entendu donc
c'était un peu flou quand elle me l'a
raconté donc je lui dis ouais c'est bien
etc mais quand j'ai écouté quand j'ai
écouté l'audio j'étais au restaurant
avec des copines
j'étais en larmes mais je sais la vidéo
enfin l'audio je ne savais pas que
c'était ma fille parce que j'ai vu un
enfant de 7 ans à sauvé sa maman en
appelant les pompiers je me suis dit oh
génial
donc j'écoute le j'écoute le bocal et en
fait bah j'ai reconnu directement la
voix de ma fille
j'ai pensé qu'elle était capable de
faire tout ça ou pas
oui vraiment ah ouais non elle est très
très elle est fute
il s'est passé combien de temps pendant
tout ce moment où vous êtes épanoui
pendant combien de temps on a
l'impression que c'est très long
ça c'est pas moi je sais pas franchement
je connais pas la date de je connais pas
s'endormit
que c'était hyper rapide elle m'a dit
que c'était elle
avait comme elle a commencé à un peu ce
entendre un peu
quand les pompiers sont arrivés
ça aurait pu être plus grave si elle
avait été intervenu
je sais pas d'après les médecins
d'étouffement
je sais pas enfin j'étais sur le ventre
en fait
pls ça m'a basculé sur le dos puis sur
le côté
c'est le sang froid de votre équipe
c'est les pompiers qui nous ont en gros
elle a suivi à la lettre tout ce que le
son qu'il lui a dit
tu restes très très calme au téléphone
tu te rends compte
mais perdue quand même parce que vu que
je reconnais la voix de enfin je sais
comment aller son tempérament on je
l'entendais qu'elle était perdue en fait
elle juste à l'écoutait elle se disait
ok il me dit c'est bien c'est pas grave
bah je continue
[Rires]
oui on t'a dit quoi même la maîtresse
elle me l'a dit aussi elle t'a dit que
j'ai fait un bon réflexe
[Rires]
je suis très fier de ce que tu as fait
tu as sauvé ta maman et tu as donné un
bel exemple à toute la France et
j'espère que le Président de la
République va te recevoir pour te mettre
la Légion de la bravoure et d'honneur
vraiment
tu aimerais bien que tu t'en fous
merci Lana merci ma chérie
mais on t'a fait plein de cadeaux
pourquoi et ta sœur
c'est pour toi et ta soeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu vas tu vas sauver beaucoup de gens
après
franchement
ma chérie c'est pour toi en tout cas et
ça nous a fait très plaisir de vous
avoir tous les deux merci ça me fait
plaisir et je suis très heureux pour toi
ma chérie
tu vas bien travailler à l'école
il voulait pas t'acheter une trottinette
si c'est bon il voulait t'encher donc
c'est bon tu en as pas pour l'instant
tout ça c'est pour toi et pour ta sœur
très bien merci à vous deux d'avoir été
avec nous merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]